hey guys it is Thursday and you'd never
guess we've actually been improvising
out intros over the last few days but
early mornings late nights and a bit of
five day losing streak and overwatch
competitive means that we lack the
mental capacity to think on our feet
this morning so for now let's go back to
scripted I'm just I'm Jess and you're
watching games but
first up call of duty modern warfare
remastered is now available on all
platform that's right you no longer need
a copy of infinite warfare to play
Activision were pretty cagey about
modern warfare remastered ever coming
out as a standalone game until last
month when it was released on ps4
Playstations exclusive deal for timed
early access to call of duty DLC saw
this one delayed on xbox and pc but the
stands have filled the bottom of the big
hourglass on table codex desk and you
can now pick up the game on all
platforms
modern warfare remastered was previously
only available as part of select special
editions of infinite warfare as the name
suggests modern warfare remastered is an
improved version of Call of Duty 4 with
the full campaign and multiplayer modes
I'm a big fan of one warfare and highly
recommend checking this one out if you
haven't already a new update for
overwatch has dropped today which among
other things introduces doom fist to the
main games after cutting your teeth in
the public test realm on PC during fist
is now available on all platforms much
like what warfare remastered you can
punch uppercuts and ground pound your
enemies who have also received several
changes in this latest update David
Hasselhoff's literal biggest man Rhine
hunt can now swing his hammer faster
saria's ultimate graviton surge that
holds enemies in place can no longer be
escaped quite characters with high
mobility like Genji and My Chemical
Romance lifelong fan club member Reaper
can now teleport a bit stealthier thanks
to a decrease in volume to his shadow
steps sound effects Deva and Genji are
also getting sound tweaks in the form of
new voice lines and sound effects that
indicate when they absorb or deflect an
enemy's ultimate finally Makris
flashbang will now slow targets heavily
which should help hinder an enemy's
escape let us know what you think of
these changes in the comments below
couple of things you guys need to know
this next story first off we write news
at about 7:00 in the morning
Australia time and also I'm not a huge
street fighter fan so when I was reading
this next story and tried to figure out
who on earth the new Street Fighter
character Abigail was I had a hard time
turns out it's a big man who makes motor
car noises because why not Street
Fighter 5 new dlc is out today and
introduces an assortment of new and
retro costumes and stages as well as the
hulking abigail apart from taking up
almost the entire screen at 8 feet and
weighing in at 584
Abigale hails from Capcom's final flight
series and is shown off stomping kicking
and pounding his opponents in the air
until they crack you can pick up a B
through the game's $30.00 days into
character pass which also includes a
coma : Edie
and two more unannounced characters you
can also get him individually for six
bucks or 100 thousand of your in-game
fight money dollars the updates new
costumes include retro outfits for Alex
Ibuki and Cherie while the new stages
include the iconic Suzaku castle Metro
City Bay Area and Kisuke families
Stadium for all the pricing for those
ones and everything else you might want
to know about Street Fighter 5 head to
our story on GameSpot that is everything
we've got for you today do let us know
what you thought of today's stories down
in that comment box and remember we'll
be back with a top 5 stories of the
entire week tomorrow